some twenty two years ago all I could
find in order to get started with German
was a dusty grammar book I had found in
my grandmother's bookcase if you think
about it nowadays we have a wealth of
possibilities compared to 20 years ago
or 15 years ago for that matter we can
download apps and use them we can
download audio books we can download
ordinary books we can talk to people on
skype we can send messages and get
feedback we can do whatever you want
that is amazing so why is it that even
with this wealth of resources and
possibilities and connections we still
struggle learning foreign languages and
that is a truth so many people just come
to me and say hey Luka how is it that I
can learn a language which would be
surprising considering the stuff that we
have nowadays and that is where a
language coach comes into play now have
you ever found yourself you know wanted
to start a language you tell yourself
okay I'm gonna learn this language and
you start by collecting language
learning material from the internet
platforms apps and all the things I said
before and then you get confused because
there's so much stuff out there that you
don't even know how to get started and
where to get started and then even if
you find your language learning material
that you want to use you don't know how
to use it or you get discouraged after
two or three days or after two or three
weeks after learning that is why a
language coach is so important he will
help you do all these things and more he
can help you find an efficient and
effective schedule which is personal to
you he can find the right material for
you he can help you give missions and
assignments that you can carry out and
he will give you feedback he will give
you moral support when it comes to you
know when your enthusiasm wanes a little
bit and he will keep you accountable
imagine a language coach and a student
like two stars or two planets orbiting
around each other the center of gravity
is exactly in the middle because it
comes to collaboration
your success is my success I cannot
teach you a language but I can help you
to make it happen
I can facilitate that process I will not
assign homework but I'll give you
missions
I won't impart lessons but I will give
you guidance I won't give you marks but
I will give you feedback with a few
coaching lessons you can literally
revolutionize your language learning
world and then you can walk down the
language path by yourself and this is an
investment for life if you want to know
more about the importance and the
function of a language coach please
click on the link below in the
description box and you can read an
extensive article I've put together on
my brand new website Luke Allen parallel
comm thank you very much for listening
to me and talk to you very very soon bye